welcome to the billionaire mindset your
30-day journey to
thinking like a billionaire now you can
just watch this video or if you want to
sign up for the entire series for free
and get the bonus pdf
companion calendar check the link in the
description below today is bonus day
five and we're going to learn from the
third richest person on the planet
at the time of this recording with a net
worth of 151.4
billion dollars mr elon musk
certainly uh being focused on something
that
you're confident will have high value to
someone else
um and just being really rigorous in
making that assessment
um because people tend to
a natural human tendency is wishful
thinking um
so a challenge for entrepreneurs is to
say well what's the difference between
really believing in your ideals and
sticking sticking to them
versus pursuing some unrealistic dream
that
doesn't actually have merit and it's
it's that is a that is a really
difficult thing to
to tell you can you tell the difference
between those two things right now so
you need to be sort of
very rigorous um in your self self
analysis
i think certainly extremely tenacious
and and then just work like hell i mean
you just have to put in
you know 80 hour 80 to 100 hour weeks
every week
and then a lot of work that that all
those things improve the odds of success
okay um i mean if if other people are
putting in 40 hour work weeks and you're
putting in
100 hour work weeks then even if
you're doing the same thing you know
that in in one year you will achieve
what they achieve
you will achieve in four months what it
takes them
a year to achieve this is widely
regarded as one of the most robotics
driven auto assembly lines
on the planet elon part of the thing i
heard about the model 3 is that there's
too many robots that made it i
agree you do you think so too that maybe
you need more people in here working we
do
in some cases the robots actually slowed
the production
yes they did we had this crazy complex
uh network of conveyor belts and it was
not working
so we got rid of that whole thing this
is cool elon
yeah realizing it needed an overhaul
musk personally took over the model 3
production line at the beginning of
april
we're aiming for really extreme levels
of precision uh more than any other
vehicle in the world he says he has
resorted to pulling all-nighters at the
plant when things get really intense i
don't have time to go home and shower
and change so i just sleep here
i want to see where is that oh yeah
i mean it's pretty boring overall really
um it's actually cold in here too
yeah i like it cool so you have a you
like it called i sleep on the couch over
there
so you're just laying here on the couch
yeah last time i was here i actually
slept
literally on the floor because the couch
was too narrow yeah i was gonna say
and elon i have to say it's not even a
comfortable couch either no it's
terrible
this is not a good couch musk feels like
all the overtime is paying off
and now he says the model 3 line is back
on track
and we're able to un unlock some of the
critical things that are holding us back
from reaching 2000 cars a week but since
then we've continued
to do 2000 cars a week do you think that
this is sustainable
this pace is sustainable yeah you need
to work if depending on how
well you want to do and particularly if
you're starting a company you need to
work super hard
so what what does super hard mean well
when my brother and i were starting our
first company
instead of getting an apartment we just
rented a small office
and we slept on the couch and we
showered at the the ymca
and uh we're so hot up we had just one
computer so
the the website was up during the day
uh and i was coding at night seven days
a week
all the time um and i i
briefly had a girlfriend in that period
and in order to be with me she'd have to
sleep in the office
so i work hard like
in it i mean every waking hour that's
that's the the thing i would i would say
if you particularly if you're starting a
company
and i mean if you do simple math say
like okay if somebody else is working 50
hours and you're working 100
you'll get twice as done as much done in
the course of a year as
the other company and generally
you want to embark on something it's
desirable
to figure out if success is at least one
of the possibilities right exactly
because for sure failure is one of the
possibilities yes
um but but ideally you want to try to
bracket it and say
success is in the envelope of outcomes
yeah um and i wasn't quite sure if that
was the case
um i mean i think success on an academic
level would have been
quite likely because you can publish
some useless paper and
uh most papers are pretty useless um you
know we have a few don't take effect
sorry i mean how many php papers are
actually used
by someone ever um i mean no it's a good
point percentage-wise it's not it's not
good yeah
uh and um so so it could have been one
of those outcomes where
uh you add some leaves to the tree of
knowledge
yeah okay um and then that leaf is nope
it's not possible
all right that goes seven years a month
um so that what so that was one path and
i was prepared to do that but then the
internet was
the error came along and i was like okay
the internet i'm pretty sure
success is one of the possible outcomes
and it seemed like i could either
do do sort of do a phd and watch the
internet happen or i could participate
and help build it in some fashion you
know
you know like i just couldn't stand the
idea of watching it happen
yeah yeah so that that's uh so i decided
to put things on hold
uh and start an internet company
and that was kind of a we we worked on
internet like publishing software maps
and directions yellow pages kind of
things
you think about a company a company is
is a group of people that are organized
to create a product or service
that's a sort of company is so in order
to
create such a thing you have to convince
others to
join you in your effort um
and and and so they have to be convinced
that
that that it's a sensible thing that
it's like that there's at least some
some good some reasonable chance of
success and if if there is success that
the reward will be commensurate with the
effort involved
um and
you know so i think that's getting
people to
to believe in what you're doing uh and
in
in you is is important um
so in the beginning there will be
there will be a few people who who who
believe in you
or what you're doing um and uh
but then over time as you make progress
that the evidence will build
and and more people will believe in what
you're doing
so um i think it's a good idea when
creating a company to
um to create it to have a demonstration
or you know if it's a product to have
like a a a good mock-up or
even if software to have good demo where
or to be able to sketch something so
people can really envision what it's
about
like that that's a try to get to that
point as soon as possible and then
iterate to make it as as real as
possible as fast as possible
we really tried hard to convince a lot
of companies
honestly i was in so many panels
but they generally were yeah generally
the settlement that was expressed that
you mentioned earlier that was pretty
much universal
especially back in say
2008 or 2007 like when we first unveiled
the roads from 2007
um yeah i mean it was just basically
they just said well you're basically a
bunch of fools well i mean generally
that sort of say like well
who starting a car company is crazy
you're going to lose all your money
i was like i think i probably will lose
all my money i agree
it wasn't like i thought it would be
successful i thought we had maybe a 10
chance of success so then people would
say you're it's going to fail and you're
going to lose
lose everything it's like yeah probably
true yeah what else is new
i don't have a mentor per se although i
try to i try to get feedback from as
many people as possible
and um so i have i have like friends and
i asked them
to you know what they think of the stuff
that and the other thing and
um you know especially you know
larry's a good relay page is a good
friend of mine value his advice a lot
and many other good friends and so
so i think it's good to solicit feedback
and particularly negative feedback
actually because you know obviously
people aren't don't love the idea of
giving you negative feedback um unless
unless it's like some you know on on
blogs they do that if you want to do
something really innovative
you have to apply a sort of first
principles analysis
not and don't don't reason by analogy
analogies
are referencing the past
so first principles means you you look
at the most fundamental truths
in a particular arena
and the things that really are
almost indisputably correct and you
reason up from there to a conclusion
and and if you if you see that that
conclusion is at odds with
with what people generally believe then
you have an opportunity
now you can't operate like that on all
things because it takes too much
mental horsepower so most of your life
you have to operate by reasoning by
analogy
but if you really want to invade you
must reason for first principles to
identify the problem
it is definitely true that i mean maybe
there are occasionally companies that
get created where
where there's not an extended period of
extreme pain
um but i'm not aware of you know very
many
such instances yeah and
so but i do think that uh
you know new great entrepreneurs are
born of every day
um and we'll continue to see amazing
companies get built
um so
yeah but i but i i would uh definitely
advise people for starting a company to
expect a
a long period of quite high difficulty
you want to make something beautiful i
mean that you want to
trigger whatever
fundamental aesthetic algorithms are
like like in your brain there's
you have i think some intrinsic uh
elements that that represent beauty um
and
and that that trigger the emotion of
appreciation of beauty in
in your your mind um and i think that
these
are these are actually relatively
consistent among people i mean not not
completely
um some people like not everyone likes
the same thing but there are there's a
lot of commonality
um and
and and and they're yeah and they're
they're but but i think
it is important to con to combine
aesthetic design with functionality
like the thing that's like if you say
like what was really hard about
say the model s or the model x was to
combine aesthetics and utility
so to balance the two you can make a car
look very good by giving it sort of
certain proportions like making it sort
of low and slim
and and
but if you uh if you do that the
utility is significantly affected i had
a lot of friends might try to talk me
out of
starting a rocket company because they
thought it was crazy and what friend of
mine made me watch a video of rockets
blowing up
[Laughter]
and you know there were just lots of
people that thought it was a really
crazy idea and there was some people
that had tried to start rocket companies
not succeeded
and that they tried to talk me out of it
and um but the thing is that
but the premise for talking out of it
was well we think you're going to lose
the money that you invest i was like
well
that was my expectation anyway so i
don't really mind if i lose
you know i mean that might but i mean
it's it's not
it's not like i was trying to figure out
the rank ordered best way to invest
money right
on that basis uh you know chose space
right i felt like that's you know i
thought wow you weren't looking at like
money money market bonds triple a bonds
rocket company you weren't like do real
estate yeah yeah you know
uh invest in shoemaking anything um
and whoa space is the highest roi yeah
that's that is not what i there's no no
it wasn't primes
um i just thought that it was important
that humanity expand beyond earth and
we weren't doing that so maybe there was
something i could do to kind of spur
spur that on you want to have like a
good competitive forcing function so
that uh you have to make the product
better
uh or or you'll lose like if you don't
make the product better and and and
improve the product for the end consumer
then then that company should
have relatively less prosperity compared
to company it makes better products
um now now the car industry you know is
actually
pretty competitive uh so that's good um
and uh and and so the good thing about a
competitive
industry is that if you make a product
that's better it's going to do better in
the marketplace
how much of your success do you
attribute to
having really audacious goals or versus
um just not being focused on the short
term
you know money coming in or investors
unfortunately i i i when one does have
to be focused on
the short term and money coming in when
creating a company because otherwise the
company will will die
so the the i think that a lot of times
people
think like creating companies
going to be fun i would say it's not
it's really not that fun i mean there
are periods of fun
and there are periods of where it's just
all for um
and particularly if you're the ceo of
the company um
you actually have a distillation of all
the worst problems in the company
um there's no point in spending your
time on things that are going right
so you only spend on things on your time
and things that are going wrong
and and there are things that are going
wrong that other people can't can't
take care of so you have like the worst
you have a filter for the crappest
problem
in the company the most pernicious and
painful problem
um so i wouldn't say it's it's i think
you have to feel
quite compelled to do it um
and have a fairly high pain threshold
and there's a friend of mine
who says like starting companies like
staring into the abyss and eating glass
and there's some truth to that um
the staring into the best part is that
you're going to be constantly facing the
extermination of the company uh because
most startups fail
uh it's like ninety percent ugly
ninety-nine percent of
startups fail so uh so you
that that's the staring into this part
you're constantly saying okay
if if if i don't get this right the
company will die
um it should be quite rightful quite
stressful
and and then um the eating glass part is
you've got you've got to do you've got
to do the problems you're going to
you're going to work on the problems
that the company needs you to work on
not the problems you want to work on
and and so that that's you end up
working on
problems that that you'd really wish you
weren't working on
and so that's the eating glass part
and that goes on for a long time if you
think you're like what is education like
you're basically downloading data and
algorithms into your brain
and it's it's actually amazingly
bad in conventional education because
like it shouldn't be like this huge
chore
um so you're making it way way better
but i mean i think i think i think a lot
of things that i would say you've
probably heard a hundred times
an effect are if if not doing like the
more you can gamify
the uh the process of learning the
better
like for my kids i do not have to
encourage them to play video games yeah
okay
i've like pry them from their hands like
like crack yes
yes like drop that crack needle yeah
yeah
you have that problem at your house too
yeah the crack isn't addictive
yeah um so it's
you know it's it's it's to agree that
you can make uh somehow
learning like a game but that then it's
better um
and i think unfortunately like a lot of
education is very bored billion
um you've got uh you know someone's
standing up there kind of lecturing at
people
and they've done the same lecture 20
years in a row and they're not very
excited about it
and that lack of enthusiasm you know is
conveyed to the students
that they're not very excited about it
they don't know why they're there
like why are we learning this stuff we
don't even know why um in fact i think a
lot of things people learn probably
there's no point
in learning them um because they never
use them
in the future because who's going to
launch a rocket into space i mean that's
just like yeah yeah exactly that never
happens
well you have to say like people i think
don't stand back and say well why
are we teaching people these things and
we should tell them
probably why we're teaching these things
because a lot of kids just
in school kind of puzzled as to why
they're there
and i think if you can explain the why
of things then that makes a huge
difference to people's motivation
yeah then they understand they
understand purpose yeah
um so i think that's pretty important
i don't think everyone needs to go you
know try to solve like some big
big world changing problem i i mean i
think that like if
i i really think like we should just
think like
are we doing something that's useful um
to the world like if you're doing
something useful that's great yeah i
just think that
like you're sort of a usefulness
optimization is
is like that's like a really good thing
um you know if you if you've done
something that's
useful to your fellow human beings
that's you've done a really good thing
and people should feel proud of doing
that
um you know it doesn't doesn't always
have to be something that's going to
change the world i mean sometimes the
world should just keep going in a
particular direction
help the world yeah it might be though
it might be going in the right direction
and i mean in a lot of ways that the
world is and we're
we are in in great shape in that if you
look at say
violent crimes um you know um
per capita in the world it's at an like
all-time low
um uh we're actually quite prosperous
uh and you know compared to in
his history um and um
you know i think there's a lot of things
to feel good about in terms of how the
world is today
um access to information is incredible i
mean
uh anyone with
like a 100 device could have has access
to
basically all the world's information
which is an incredible thing
um and um yeah so i honestly i just
think like the best thing for people to
try to do is say hey what is something i
can do that would really be
be useful to the world and just do that
you know that's great
first of all my goal is not disruption
for the sake of instruction um
i i really think there's okay there's
some
important things we have to solve in
order for the future to be good yeah i
would say like my
you know my sort of algorithm or
optimization is like okay
what set of things do we need to do uh
to ensure that the
increase the probability of the future
is going to be good yeah and so
if we if we have to solve sustainable
energy yeah this is total logical if we
do not solve sustainable energy
then we have unsustainable energy then
it's just a matter of time before
things go before civilization collapses
we must but
even beside even if there was not an
environmental issue
uh since the availability of oil is
limited
yeah this is not something we can
sustain long term
yeah my original interest in electric
vehicles was actually not environmental
it was out of concern
just you know studying physics and i'm
like wait a second yeah we we
immediately transitioned to
uh solar electric yeah uh or we're gonna
have a problem
and and we run out of oil civilization
collapses that's a problem now of course
the environmental concerns uh have added
to the
uh urgency um because the the more
uh co2 co2 we put in the oceans and
atmosphere
the more we increase the probability
that uh something will go wrong
like i said like things are much more
probability as opposed to certainty
uh but i think it's an unwise experiment
to dramatically increase the co2 yeah in
the atmosphere and oceans yeah uh
just given that we know we need to
transition anyway because we'll run out
of oil
yeah so why run that experiment it's not
it doesn't make any sense
um we know we have to transition to a
sustainable energy economy
um then let's just get on with it yeah
you know let's just get on with it
and not run the crazy experiment and see
if the what happens if the atmosphere
has
2000 ppm co2 this is crazy
i think just generally the the path to
leadership should not be
uh through um you know basically
mba business school situation it's it's
like it should be
kind of work your way up do useful
things and um
you know and there's there's a bit too
much of the somebody goes to
a high-profile mba school and then kind
of parachutes in
as the as the leader but they don't
actually know how things work
um they that you know they could be good
at say powerpoint presentations or
something like that
um and they can present well but they
don't actually know how things work
because they do not um you know they
don't
they they they like parachuted in
instead of like working their way out
yeah
yeah yeah they did they never went
through an apprenticeship from yeah
yeah yeah they're so they're they're
they're kind of like just not
aware of what's really needed for uh you
know to make to make great products
um so i mean i don't want to trash
mbas too much here and i actually do
have a dual undergrad
wharton undergrad and physics um at
upenn
so um you know so i have like you know
it's
i have direct exposure to to uh
um you know to business school and i
went
you know to do undergrad business school
with with physics
but um and i was a teaching assistant
for two
semesters and i graded mbas and uh
undergrads
um so uh but i think it's just a little
bit too much
like like people look at mba school as
like i want to parachute into being the
boss instead of earning it
and like i don't think that's that's
good this was x.com was a precursor to
paypal basically
yeah you merged with confinity and it
became paypal
major success yeah it worked out better
than we expected
um yeah um
so yeah confinity
so initially confinity and x.com started
out with from slightly different
directions and then converged to the
same point
with with x the thought was to create uh
integrated set of financial services
so that you can go to one place and do
all of your financial anything
and and then as a feature we have the
ability to transfer money or securities
or anything simply by entering a unique
identifier
so like a you know email address or
phone number or something like that
um and uh when we demo the system
the hard stuff which was the integration
of all the
financial services people would not be
interested in but they'd be really
interested in it and being able to
transfer money using an email address
you know that was actually quite easy um
and so we focused our energy on that
um and although it's easy in principle
it
uh what gets really hard is is adding um
security while still keeping it easy to
use
so because you know it's like the woolly
lemon quote like why do people
why do i bank because that's where the
money is so a lot of people run paypal
same reason um and and so
you can you can dial up the security to
a really high level but then you're
going to make it very hard to use
um and and so that that was
that was one of the toughest things we
were wrestled with we're focused on like
it it is important to have that
have the objective be right um as far as
talking so much about the importance of
making wealth mars a self-sustaining as
building a self-sustaining city on mars
um if if that's the objective then
obviously
you know just putting some satellites in
orbit or
is not that that's not important you
have to achieve full and rapid
reusability
amp size full and rapid reusability is
only relevant to the degree it's rapid
and complete
and uh and then you also have to do
orbital refilling this is essential
as well um and uh and then
um propellant production on mars also
essential
so uh you know
and with that as the goal then
you know that that means that that that
creates i think a good forcing function
for
radical innovation because in the
absence of radical innovation we have no
chance of meeting that goal
um whereas if i go simply
you know defeat lockheed and boeing or
something like that
that we would probably achieve i've
already
that really wasn't even a thing you know
i wish it was
um yeah like they're they're not really
trying to do
they're not even trying to do
reusability which is bizarre because
they make planes that are reusable
um so i mean if they if they talk to
like you know if they talk to one of
their customers about bias or
a lucky fighter jet or boeing aircraft
like hey we're going to sell you a
737 confused once and it's and it's not
737 max
but that was that turns out that was a
single user plan at times
um but it really uh
would it would be an absurd thing for
them to sell a
single-use aircraft but they feel quite
comfortable selling a single-use rocket
um and anyway but if our goal is simply
we're going to have to be the leaders in
launching the conventional satellites
that exist
uh we would probably approach that in on
a sort of a logarithmic basis
where you know you get there and you
sort of slowly make progress towards
doing
10 launches a year 12 launches a year
and while they do six or something like
that
um but since the goal is hey we need to
make life multi-planetary before it's
too late
um and time really matters so
we're our states us it's like we're
shooting for mars not just the moon
it's not much suit for the moon shoot
for mars um and then and then the
you know these these competitive things
are are kind of small
things along the way unless somebody
else is shooting for mars they will not
be competitive
with something as pedestrian as
launching a few satellites into earth
orbit
the physics training is a very good
training where
it's a good framework for reasoning
where you're trained to
think about first principles and reason
from there
and that means boiling things down to
the most fundamental truths
and then connecting those truths in a
way to try to
understand how reality is because you
know physics has this problem where
they're trying to figure out things that
are totally counter-intuitive
and so they had to have a framework for
for getting there like quantum mechanics
is
incredibly counter-intuitive but it's
true
um and so you had so physics developed a
for for figuring out
things that aren't obvious and that's
why i think it's it's not
it's it's a lot of advice but it's it's
the right framework
you think about the future you want a
future that's better than the past and
so if we had something like the
hyperloop i think that would be like
cool like you'd look forward to the day
that that
was working you know and and it's
something like that even if it was only
iota only
was in one place you know from l.a san
francisco or
new york to dc or something like that
then
um it would be cool enough that it would
be like a tourist attraction yeah
like a riot yeah yeah so even if if
some of the initial assumptions didn't
work out the economics didn't didn't
work out quite as as one expected it
would be like cool enough like i want to
journey that place just to just to write
on that thing that would be pretty cool
um and so that's i think how
if you cope with the new technology it
should feel like that you should really
like if you told it to an objective
person would they look forward to the
day that that thing
became available and like you know be
pretty exciting to do something like
that
um or an aircraft like i thought it was
really disappointing when that when the
concorde was taken out of commission and
there was no
supersonic transport available
and of course the 787 has had some
issues yeah um
so um but it's but the thing is the 787
even the best case scenario is only a
slightly better version of the triple
seven yeah
and it's like okay but not that exciting
i was just saying
that you know you want to take a moment
to appreciate things in life
and the sensations um
food's incredible and
like there's just so many good things
that you can experience some of them
cost nothing
really you know have a walk in nature
or just a nice meal and it's like wow
that's pretty great you know and uh
we should take a moment to appreciate
these these uh
little things the big things um the
things that move your heart
i think that's probably the meaning of
life as close
definitions as i can think things that
i've chosen have not been
um i've not been trying to
optimize on a risk-adjusted return basis
so
there are uh like i would not say that i
went into
the rocket business the car business or
the solar business thinking that
it's a it's a great opportunity i just
thought that
that something needed to be done in in
these industries
in order to make a difference and that's
why i did it
so um
but in general i do think it's worth
thinking about like
what you whether what you're doing is
going to result in disruptive change or
not
if it's just incremental it's unlikely
to
to be something major it's got to be
something that's substantially better
than than what's
gone on before how do you keep your
focus on the big picture when you're
constantly
faced with we could be out of business
in a month
well it's just a very small percentage
of mental energies on the
on the big picture like you know you
know where you're generally heading for
and and the actual path is going to be
some sort of zigzaggy thing
in that direction um and try not to
deviate too far from the path
that that you want to be on but you're
going to have to do that to some degree
um but i don't want to i don't want to
diminish the i mean i think the product
the profit motive is
is a is a good one if the rules of an
industry are properly set up
so there's nothing fundamentally wrong
with profit in fact profit just means
that
uh people are paying you more for the
whatever you're doing
then you're spending to create it that's
a good thing
and if you're not if that's not the case
then you'll be out of business and
rightfully so
you're you're not adding enough value i
think that the way that we currently do
education is
is wrong and and we're when you see
something like
the khan academy and so forth that's
probably going in the right direction
i mean generally you want education to
be like as close to
a video game as possible like a good
video game like
you do not need to tell your kid to play
video games they will play video games
on autopilot all day
so if you can make it interactive and
engaging
then then you can make education far
more compelling and
far easier to do
so i think that's how it should be and
it shouldn't be that you've got like
these grades where people move in
lockstep and so everyone
goes through you know goes like normally
you
will go through english math uh
science and so forth from like fifth
grade to sixth grade to seventh grade
like it's an assembly line
but but people are not objects on an
assembly line
that's a ridiculous notion
people learn and are interested in
different things
at different paces so you really want to
disconnect the whole grade level three
thing from the subjects
allow people to progress at the fastest
pace that they can
or interested in in each subject you're
running
you're ceo of two companies you're
chairman of solarcity
talk about time management how on earth
do you do this
well do you get any sleep uh yeah
sometimes not enough
sleep is really great uh because because
if
i find if i don't get enough sleep then
i'm i'm quite grumpy um
i mean obviously i think most people are
that way um and
and also um like i try to sort of figure
out what's the
right amount of sleep because like i
found i could have
i could drop below a certain threshold
of sleep and although i'd be awake more
hours and i could sustain it
i would get less done because
my mental acuity would be affected
so i found generally the right number
for me is around six to six and a half
hours
on average per night um that's not too
bad
yeah right and any other tips on average
though
any other tips on just managing to run
two companies simultaneously
i mean do you do you find i mean i know
you're up here monday tuesday is it
all tesla when you're up in silicon
valley and all
spacex wednesday thursday
having a sort of
having a smartphone is incredibly
helpful because that means you can do
email
during interstitial periods like you're
in a car you're walking in the bathroom
everywhere
you can do email practically when you're
awake
and uh and so that's really helpful to
have
email for spacex and tesla integrated on
my phone
um and then uh
and then it's just you have to apply a
lot of hours to actual working
actually working so the way i generally
do it is i'll be
working at spacex on monday and then
monday night flight to the bay area
spent tuesday and wednesday at the bay
area
then at tesla and then fly back on
wednesday night
spend thursday and friday at spacex
um in in the last several months then i
would fly back here
on a saturday and either spend saturday
and sunday
at tesla or spend saturday at tesla and
sunday at spacex
what do you look for in the people you
hire especially the engineers
i'd really just look for evidence of
exceptional ability
so it's not at least aspirationally like
sometimes these things get
messed up in recruiting or the
recruiting photo beings
it ends up being wrong like i sometimes
wonder with tesla
if nikola tesla applied to tesla would
we even give him an interview
it's not clear you know this guy came
from like some weird college and
somewhere in eastern europe i think he's
got some odd mannerisms
no we don't know if we should give an
interview like i worry that that's
actually what we do instead of like
it should be like man [ __ ] this this
this
kid's super smart what does he want
we'll pay him anything
that should be that should be the
reaction if nikola tesla applies you
know
to tesla um ironically but
so i can tell you the intent is we're
looking for evidence of exceptional
ability
uh and it really doesn't matter if
you're wanting to graduate high school
or college or anything
we're just looking for evidence of
exceptional ability uh such that
it would be a good predictor for doing
exceptional things spacex
is it going to be a business kind of
tourism in
in orbit or is it more kind of plan b
if things on earth do not develop as
well it's not exactly a plan
b it's it's more that i think i think
there's two
two aspects to this uh one is that we
want to have a future
that is inspiring and exciting and what
are the things that you find inspiring
and exciting about the future
i think one a future where we are a
space faring civilization
and out there among the stars i think
that's
every kid gets excited about that you
don't even need to teach them
they just get it's like instinctive and
so we we it's very important for us to
have reasons to
like reasons to be excited about life
like when you wake up in the morning it
can't just be about problems
it's okay i know everyone in this room
deals with a lot of tough problems
but you know it's got to be more than
that so
you know i think a future where you can
say hey even if it's not you
there's going to be people out there
they're going to we can have a base on
the moon
we're going to have a you know a city on
mars maybe
go further the moons of jupiter and
everything i think that's a very
exciting future
you want to make something beautiful i
mean that you want to
trigger whatever
fundamental aesthetic algorithms are
like like in your brain there's
you have i think some intrinsic uh
elements that that represent beauty um
and
and that that trigger the emotion of
appreciation of beauty
in in your your mind um
and i think that these are these are
actually
relatively consistent among people i
mean
not completely um some people like not
everyone likes the same thing
but there are there's a lot of
commonality but i think it is important
to
combine aesthetic design with
functionality
like the thing that's like if you say
like what was really hard about
say the model s or the model x was to
combine aesthetics and utility
so to balance the two you can make a car
look
very good by giving it sort of
certain proportions like making it sort
of low and slim
and and
[Music]
but if you uh if you do that the
utility is significantly affected to
make a sports car look good is
relatively easy
but to make a sedan look good or an suv
look good is quite difficult
really pay attention to the little
details
the the nuances of of design and shape
and form function and
[Music]
the you know just the way it looks in
different lights and
when something's off the little thing
how do you experience that
that drives me bananas yeah
i mean it's and it the the problem is
like if you
you can train yourself to to pay
attention to the tiny details i think
almost anyone can
um although it it this is a very much
double-edged sword because then you see
all the little details um and then
little things drive you crazy
so but like most people don't they don't
see they don't consciously see the small
details but they
they do subconsciously see them like you
you sort of your mind takes in a result
of
the overall you know an overall
impression and and you you know if
something
is appealing or not even though you may
not be able to
point out exactly why um and it's it's a
summation of of these many small details
so most of us experience it as a oh i
think that's ugly or i think that's
beautiful or like wow that's elegant but
yeah
can't break it down you mentioned
something in passing like you can train
yourself in this though yeah you can
train yourself i think
you can make yourself pay attention to
to why
um you're essentially to bring the
subconscious awareness into conscious
awareness god i wish i could do that how
do you do that
just just pay really close attention
almost like a meditation on the object
and trying to find the details like why
do i not like this is that what
yeah just look look closely and
carefully or maybe i just blank out the
word doubt
so uh no i mean i totally frank i
doubted us too
so i thought we you know had maybe
when starting spacex maybe had a 10
chance of reaching orbit so
so you know to those who who doubted us
i was like well i think you're probably
right
you know um i mean there were times uh
that i was told like uh because i was
taking the money that i earned from
from paypal and enrolling into to create
spacex and
tesla and and end up spending it all it
wasn't the intention but
um and and and uh almost both companies
went bankrupt frankly 2008 was a tough
year
um you know it took us took us four
attempts just to get to orbit with
falcon one
um and uh so
but a lot of times i was you know i
people would tell me this joke like
how do you make a small fortune in the
rock industry you start with a large one
is the
punchline and i was like okay i already
heard that joke
12 000 times you know so
so anyway um and it was it almost came
true
um you know we just barely made it there
that fourth launch of falcon one that's
all the money we had for that fourth
launch
and then uh and that wasn't even enough
to save the company we also then had to
win the nasa cargo resupply contract
um so that that came a little after you
know a little bit later
all right towards the end of 2008. uh
those are the two
key things that that saved spacex
otherwise we would have we would have
you know not made it so
um so yeah i think those those doubters
were
their probability assessment was correct
um but fortunately
uh vader smiled upon us and brought us
to this day
i wanted to spur ideas and thinking
about
the long-term need to
capture carbon and
you know i think this is one of those
things that's going to take a while to
figure out what the right solution is
and especially to figure out what what
the best economics are
for for co2
removal and
and all the things i think through all
the consequences you don't want the cure
to be worse than the disease yeah
uh so uh you know sometimes people say
well just plant a bunch of trees i'm
like that's not so easy you know
like like a trillion trees sure exactly
and then you gotta like okay well
how you get fertilizer are you going to
water them where's the water going to
come from
uh what habitat are you potentially
destroying where the trees used to be
it's it's not it's not just a no-brainer
if there's go plant about it but it's
not to say that's not a good viable
option
we should plant some trees i i'm in
favor of planting trees
it's just not a question of like okay um
you know there are like vast sections of
like like the sahara desert or or uh
the you know the some large barren areas
very dry areas in the u.s um where you
couldn't theory
plant a lot of trees but you're going to
need a lot of water yeah and you're
going to
like like you're going to have to
cultivate them it's not like they don't
just
throw some cheese on the ground we'll
drop them from orbit
yeah and i mean so just i think it'll be
good to sort of
uh kind of frame the the frame the
debate
and and understand okay what things are
really going to move the needle how much
are they going to move the needle
um
if we're talking about getting tens or
hundreds of billions of tons of carbon
in what form will that carbon be yeah
will it be stable over time
um and like i said like what is this
going to cost humanity to do however
it's paid for
what what is it going to cost what's the
thing that's going to
take the you know be most affordable
let's say
running a public company does have its
drawbacks um
so you're not in a hurry no
okay um i mean in the case of tesla and
spacex
we had to raise capital um and and we
had kind of complex equity structure
that needed to be resolved by
by going public um and
um and so so i thought we we kind of
needed to do that in those two cases
we don't have to do that in spacex i
think i think there's a good chance it
will at some point in the future
but but spacex's objectives are super
long term
and and the market is is not so
i'm a bit worried that if we did go
public certainly if we're in public too
soon
that it that that market pressure would
would force us to do
uh short-term things and abandon kind of
long-term projects
like going to mars right greenwire's
very long term i always thought we would
fail
so this is oh it's all upside down
you know i thought maybe we had a 10
chance of reaching orbit starting out so
then uh if people thought
when we started spacex they said oh
you're going to fail
so i agree i think we probably will fail
yeah it's worth trying anyway yeah
yeah how's that for honesty huh yeah
this this i said i'd lose
like you know lose all the money from
paypal i was like well you're probably
right
you know and we're almost there we first
three launches the falcon one didn't
work
then the fourth one we scraped together
some parts and then that one worked and
if that one hadn't worked
would have been that would have been it
for us so um
i really believe in the future of space
and and i think it's important that we
become a space frank civilization
and and not be out there among the stars
and i think that's one of the things
that
you know makes people excited about the
future and
we want the things that are in science
fiction novels and
movies not to be science fiction forever
we want to be real one day
other car companies just really want to
outsource battery technology not not
even not even making the like this
battery module and cell
but they're they're obviously
outsourcing the cells but even
outsourcing the modules in the packs
yeah you know and it's like
they're really not thinking about
fundamental chemistry improvements and
it is so i i should say a bit about like
like
electric vehicles and and and so or
sustainable energy
in general it you know i said it was it
was pretty i think obvious to
not not just me to me but to a lot of
people may even go back 30 years or
longer
that we must have a sustainable energy
solution in fact it's
it's total logical if it's uns if it's
if it's not sustainable
we must at some point find an
alternative to it
and so even if there were no
environmental impact to
the sort of a fossil fuel economy then
we would run out of them
and then we'd have economic collapse and
civilization would fall apart so so that
that was actually my initial motivation
for
electric vehicles it's like okay we've
got to have a solution that does not
require um mining hydrocarbons
uh that that that is sustainable in the
long term
it was not actually initially from an
environmental standpoint because i did
not
realize the gravity of the environmental
situation at that time
and i thought actually for sure by now
we'd have electric cars
young people globally want to be like
elon musk
what's your advice today i think that
probably they shouldn't want to be
you it i think it sounds better than it
is okay
um yeah it's
uh not as much fun being me as you'd
think
i don't know you don't think so there's
definitely it could be worse for sure
but it's um
i i i'm not sure i would i'm not sure i
want to be me
okay but
if
you know i think advice i mean if you
want to make
progress in things i think that
um but the the best analytical framework
for understanding the future is physics
i'd recommend studying the uh
the thinking process around physics like
not just not not the equations i mean
equations certainly they're helpful
but the the the way of thinking in
physics is
it's the best framework for
understanding things that are
counterintuitive
[Music]
and you know always taking the position
that you are some degree wrong and your
goal is to be less wrong over time
one of the biggest mistakes people
generally make and i'm guilty of it too
is wishful thinking
you know like you want something to be
true even if it isn't true
um and so you ignore the things that
you ignore the real truth because of
what you want to be true
um this is a very difficult trap to
avoid
and like i said certainly one that i
find myself
in having problems with
but if you just take that approach of
you're always to some degree wrong
and your goal is to be less wrong and
and solicit critical feedback
particularly from friends like friends
particularly friends
if somebody loves you they want the best
for you they don't want to tell you the
bad things
so you have to ask them okay you know
and said really i
really do want to know and then they'll
tell you
first of all you don't need college
learning learn stuff
okay everything is available basically
for free
you can learn anything you want for free
it is not a question of learning
there is a value that colleges have
which is like
you know seeing whether somebody's is
can somebody work hard at something
including a bunch of sort of annoying
homework assignments
and still do their homework assignments
and and kind of soldier through and and
get it done
you know that's that's like the main
value of college and then also you know
if you if you
probably want to hang around with a
bunch of people your own age for a while
instead of going right into the
workforce
so i think colleges are basically for
fun and to prove you can do your chores
but they're not for learning i think
failure is bad i don't think it's good
but if if something's important enough
then you
you do it even though the risk of
failure is high um
and and so i think my advice if somebody
wants to start a company is they should
bear in mind that the most likely
outcome
is is that it's not going to work and
they should reconcile themselves to that
past strong possibility um and they
should only do it if they feel that they
they're they're really compelled to do
it you know right
um because it's it's
it's gonna the way starting company
works is like usually in the beginning
it's
the very beginning it's kind of fun um
and then
it's really hellish for for a number of
years
you talked about chewing glass yeah
there's
there's a friend of mine who's a
successful entrepreneur um and uh
started actually his career around the
same time as i did and he has a good
good good phrase his name is bully uh he
said yeah
you're starting companies like eating
glass and staring into the abyss
um and you agree with that
generally true um yeah
and and and if you don't eat the glass
you're not going to be successful
well we have a lot of good good people
at spacex that
a lot of really talented people
in fact i wonder like sometimes how we
can make use of their talents
in the best way because you know i think
we're often
not using their talents in the best way
yeah but you know to the point of the
question i was just asked i want to make
sure
tesla recruiting does not have anything
that says requires
university because that's absurd uh
but there is a requirement of evidence
of exceptional ability
like you just can't if you're trying to
do something exceptional they must have
evidence of exceptional ability i don't
consider going to college
evidence of exceptional ability in fact
ideally you dropped out and did
something
i mean obviously you know you look at
like
you know gates is a pretty smart guy he
dropped down
uh john was pretty smart he dropped out
you know
larry ellison smart guy he dropped out
like
obviously not needed
so did shakespeare even go to college
probably not what sort of things do you
look for in people
or in processes that make the workforce
better
sure well i think the massive
thing that can be done is to make sure
your incentive structure is such that
uh innovation is rewarded and lack of
innovation is punished
there's got to be a characteristic so
if somebody is innovating
and doing making good progress
then they should be promoted sooner
and if somebody is completely failing to
innovate
not every role requires innovation but
uh if they're
in a role where innovation is
should be happening and it's not
happening then they should
either not be promoted or exited and let
me tell you you'll get promote you could
you'll you'll get innovation real fast
your actual total mass
of a steel
of a reusable steel spacecraft is less
than that of the most advanced carbon
fiber
vehicle you could possibly imagine yeah
wow but this
happened by accident by the way this may
sound like some great insight but
it actually happened because we were
moving too slowly on composite
um and i was like we cannot move this
slowly or we'll go bankrupt so
just do this with steel so yeah i mean
the design has to be
focused on problem solving otherwise
you're going to spend too much time
trying to figure you don't start with a
yeah
yeah i'm like sort of taken to
management management by rhyming
if the schedule is schedule is long your
design is wrong
right this is very true
i mean tesla really faced the severe
threat threat of death
due to the model 3 production ramp
essentially
the company was bleeding money like
crazy and and just
if if we didn't solve these problems in
a very short period of time uh we would
die
uh and it was extremely difficult to
solve them how close to death did you
come
we are within single budget weeks
22 hours a day or like what how many
hours working yeah seven days a week
sleeping in the factory uh i worked
every day from i worked in the
paint shop general assembly body shop
you ever worry about yourself
imploding like it's just too much
absolutely no one should
put this many hours into work
this is not good people should not work
this hard i'm not
they should not do this this is very
painful
painful in what tense it's because my
heart's my brain
and my heart so it's
this is not recommended for anyone i
just did it because
if i didn't do it then tesla your
chances would die
the real way i think you you actually
achieve intellectual property protection
is by innovating fast enough if your
rate of innovation
is high then you don't need to worry
about protecting vip
because other companies will be copying
something that you did years ago
and that's fine you know
just make sure your rate of innovation
is fast
speed is really speed of innovation is
what is what matters
um and i do i do say this to my teams
like
uh quite a lot that innovation per unit
time as i go innovation per year if you
want to say like is is what matters not
innovation
absent time because if you wanted to
make say
um 100 improvement in something and that
took
100 years or one year that's
radically different so um it's like
what is your rate of innovation that
that matters and is the rate of
innovation
um is that accelerating or decelerating
and a weird thing happens when companies
get big is that most companies
um or organizations the bigger they get
they tend to
get less innovative um
not just less innovative on a per person
basis but less innovative in the
absolute
and i think this is probably because the
incentive structure is not
uh is not there for innovation
it's not enough to use words to
encourage innovation
the incentive structure must be aligned
with that
that's fundamental when i was in in high
school i thought i'd most likely be
doing physics out of particle
accelerator
so that's what as um
physics and computers i mean i got
distinctions in two areas in physics and
computer science and those were
yeah so my two best subjects and i
and then i thought okay well that i want
to figure out what's the nature of the
universe and
um so you know go try to
working with people banging particles
together see what happens
um and um and then it
sort of things went along and the the
superconducting super collider got
cancelled
in the us and that actually was like
whoa you know
what if i i'm working at a collider
it's been all these years and then the
government just cancels it wow
and then that would i was like hopefully
i can do that
so um so it's like
well we roll back a little um
like i tried to figure out i had like
this existential crisis
and i was about 12 years old or
something and and i was like well what
does the world mean
wait what's it all about are we living
some meaningless existence
and then i met i made the mistake of
reading nietzsche and job now and yes
and i'm like
wow don't do that it's not it's
not to not seem to be a little older i
think no no
actually lately these days i sort of
rearranged it so i was like
you know it's actually he's not that bad
wait he's he's got issues he's got
issues
no question about it but but you know
it's anyway um
so uh but then the hitchhiker's guide to
the galaxy
douglas adams uh which is like quite
really quite a good book on philosophy i
think
and i was like okay we don't really know
what the answer is
obviously uh so but the universe the
universe is the answer
and really what are the questions we
should be asking to better
understand the nature of the universe
and so then to the degree that we
expand the scope and scale of
consciousness
then we'll better be able to answer the
ask the questions
and understand the
why we're here or what it's all about
and so we should
sort of take the set of actions that are
most likely to result in us
understanding what questions to ask
about the nature of the universe
now i've got some special bonus clips
that i think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the
billionaire mindset question of the day
i wanna know what was your single
biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week
also if you've already got your
billionaire mindset companion pdf
calendar
get ready for another amazing video
tomorrow or if you don't have it yet you
can get it for free
in the first line of the description
below and if you're enjoying this
billionaire mindset series give me a
mindset in hashtag comments below so i
can celebrate you
in the beginning nobody wanted a tesla i
can tell you that
the the the when we made the original
sort of roadster sports car
people like why would i want an electric
car that's my gasoline
car works fine i'm like no electric car
is better i should try it
and it was hard to get people to
do a test drive first one nobody knew
who we were
and then we heard this company and like
yeah we're named after nikola tesla you
know that guy nope
um so
for sure we were doing push in the
beginning because people said
there was no one telling us that they
wanted an electric car so it was not it
was not out of like
you know it was like lots of people
coming up to me saying hey i really want
an electric car
i heard that zero times um
some people like it's like man we're
gonna make an electric car and show that
these things can be good
um and then people want them um
you know it's like i think it's like
henry ford said that like the you know
we're talking about the model t it's
like if you asked the public what they
wanted they'd say
a faster horse so if you did like a big
survey and say well hey
public before automobiles
what would you like it's like well i'd
like my horse to go three miles an hour
faster and eat less food
and uh you know be stronger
and live longer and that kind of thing
there will be basically a bunch of
incremental improvements on horse um
because people when you say like what
about an automobile that car that drives
itself like what are you talking about
that's not that sounds crazy um but
when you actually make an automobile and
give it to people and say okay
now this is a horse where you can keep
it in the barn and if you leave for a
month it's still alive
[Laughter]
yeah so carry more
more weight than a horse and go further
and that kind of thing so
anyway the it's like when when it's a
radically
new product people don't know that they
want it because it's just not in their
in their scope i think when they first
started making tvs
they did a nationwide survey i think
this might have been like
46 or 48 it's like famous nationwide
survey
will you ever buy a tv now i was like 96
percent of respondents said no
some crazy number like basically
everyone's like would you buy a tv
and maybe they put a price in there or
something i don't know but it was
famously almost everyone said they would
not buy tv
but they didn't know what they're
talking about if you want to sign up for
the
entire billionaire mindset series for
free and get the companion bonus pdf
calendar
check the link right there next to me i
think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there